my pick is about an issue a lot of
people are thinking about right now that
is summer travel
the temperatures are heating up vaccine
numbers are going up and millions of
people are ready to get on the road or
board an airplane
also new cdc guidelines recommend
delaying travel
until you're fully vaccinated but more
and more people are getting vaccinated a
recent survey by the travel website the
points guy
says americans still favor outdoor trips
to national parks and beaches
but you got to get there joining us now
brian kelly ceo and founder of the point
sky website brian good morning to you
uh big question i think a lot of people
are going to have uh what kind of deals
are there out there the the the
airlines have not been in great shape
and they may still want to coax people
out to buy that ticket
yeah there are absolutely still deals to
be had but not
usually to the most popular destinations
right so summer 2021 is looking to be a
lot similar to 2020
national parks hawaii alaska
um and airfares to those places have
skyrocketed but you gotta hunt for the
deals
try to go in off-peak weeks or travel
during the week
um but you can definitely still find
those deals so brian it occurs to me
that as more people try to travel
because they're vaccinated the
airline industry and other tourist
businesses are going to start increasing
their prices maybe by
a lot are we going to see something like
price gouging this summer uh oh
absolutely yeah we're already seeing it
in hawaii it can be 500
a day to rent a car um
you know the carbine market has gone
through the roof because they
the car rental companies a year ago sold
a lot of their inventory not thinking
demand would bounce back this quickly
we're seeing the same with airfares
although there's still a lot of good
flights to be
you know flight deals to be had uh but
you know if you're looking at hawaii or
miami
hotels and flights can be way more than
they were pre-pandemic
let me just say brian kelly you look
like you've gotten some sun from
somewhere mr kelly sitting there looking
all tanned and cool
with your blue eyes and your salmon
colored jacket i like it i like it
so listen to tony's point a lot more
people are getting vaccinated if you're
vaccinated
where do you think is the best place to
go in terms of low coven
and what are the best deals to get there
yeah so iceland's a top destination they
just now if you're vaccinated you don't
even have to worry about getting tested
on arrival or quarantining
icelander just came out with 330 flights
so that's a top destination
of course there's also so much you can
do outdoors not in a crowded city
um but yeah it really depends on each
country you know
right now we're seeing a fourth surge in
france and germany
so as much as i want to visit you know
continental europe this summer
it's going to be dicey until they get
that under control and also their
vaccine rollout's been pretty slow
if you do want europe i bet greece will
happen this summer
but the seychelles if you're looking for
a far-flung destination and you're
vaccinated
seychelles are allowing vaccine
passports as well and it's one of the
most beautiful island destinations i've
ever been to
wait can i ask you about mexico asking
for a friend
mexico you know is still struggling with
the vaccine rollout but if you're fully
vaccinated as the cdc came out two weeks
ago you have a very low risk to yourself
um so yeah i think the caribbean i got
my golden tan in the british virgin
islands a couple weeks ago it was
amazing not to rub it in um
but yes brian we've been talking a lot
about the cruise industry
trying to make a comeback do you see it
come back for them anytime soon
absolutely but just yesterday the state
of florida is suing the cdc because the
cdc needs to sign off for cruises to
leave from the u.s but they don't
from other countries so what we've seen
is that cruises now are going to be
leaving from bermuda
and jamaica as soon as this summer so
and we've heard from the cruise industry
that bookings are way up
but you will need to be vaccinated to go
on most cruises
um and we are seeing foreign airlines
like qanus
uh uh demanding you know or requiring
that people be vaccinated
uh whenever they start to fly again not
every airline is going to mandate it but
the cruise ships will anthony i think we
should mention it brian i know you would
point this out people who had
flights canceled last year at this time
they probably have credits and vouchers
they may expire so before you book check
that
yeah absolutely
check your existing vouchers if they're
expiring soon a lot of the airlines have
already
uh been nice and extended them even
longer some airlines are a little bit
naughtier than others so look at the
fine print on your voucher yeah even if
you don't have travel plans today
use the voucher book something in the
future because you never know the number
one thing is you don't want to lose
that voucher so you don't have to do it
can't wait for my next trip all right
brian
thank you so much we'll be right back